we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p very strange
topic for today's voicemail take a
listen to this hey David I wanted to
talk about some articles that I've seen
recently about Pete bitter judge and
some some pockets of the left that are
apparently accusing him of not being gay
enough which I find to be slightly
unnerving in in in a democratic field
that has more diversity than I think
I've ever seen in my lifetime or we have
an Asian man a Jewish man a women of
color everything that you can imagine
why are we still seeing these sorts of
these sorts of attacks and they're not
in the mainstream so far as I can tell
but certainly areas and enclaves of the
left that sort of want to keep pushing a
very specific and focused kind of
diversity and I you know identity
politics yeah listen I have not seen
this III mean I'm not saying it doesn't
exist I've not seen anyone say Pete
Buddha judge is not gay enough that that
I mean what I don't even understand how
that qualifies as an argument if someone
is saying that I want to hear about it
because it's so ridiculous at its face
but again I think it's really important
even if it exists anecdotally we
shouldn't on the Left get pulled into
going completely out of our way to
refute ideas that are barely relevant
and this is where a lot of that you know
sometimes I'll appear on other shows and
I'll get asked about identity politics
on the Left I'll get asked about you
know free free speech limiting leftists
on college campuses or whatever and I've
been very critical of those things but I
think that we need to be critical of
them in proportion to how serious of an
issue it is this thing of pita judge
isn't gay enough if it's real which I
haven't even heard it's not as the
caller says part of the mainstream
discussion about people who to judge and
so our engagement with these bad ideas
and and niche ideas that are barely out
there dumb ideas
needs to be minimal because there's no
point in
getting overly involved in refuting
ideas that very few people hold and that
are barely relevant within the political
discussion because discussion that's
been my view call stuff out that doesn't
make sense when there's an opportunity
when you see it but the last thing I'm
gonna do is start going around trying to
figure out who's saying boo de jedge
isn't gay enough to then focus on
criticizing it there's much bigger ideas
to talk about and way bigger fish to fry
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we'll talk about the White House
asking the Navy to hide a warship named
after late Senator John McCain and much
more get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at join
pakman.com I'll speak to you then